ever since i was a little kid i've loved
her i remember
being five six years old i'm going to
sleep watching poker
and i have just like thinking numbers i
can calculate read people stuff like
that so when i was 18
i got a fake id i went to the casino and
i was just like boom this is my purpose
for life
for a long time 22 now for four years
i've just been consumed
with poker money you know and trying to
make it i was looking for the truth for
a long time
and i was just into some crazy stuff
like i was that eccentric guy who was
like
always trying you know going to buddhist
temples and
meditating and taking cold showers and
doing you know crazy type of stretching
and
you know new age spirituality all this
stuff but
it's just because i was the truth and
religion is really complicated
and i think that you know the religions
that are false are complicated on
purpose
because i i kept trying to find god and
i just
it felt impossible to be honest with you
you know but it's not
the whole message um it says i know i've
heard angel say this
and i know all of you if you just take
little bits and pieces
and choose whatever you want to choose
it doesn't really work so you know like
meditation is good
you know eating healthy or whatever
whatever you get into it's all good
um but with islam i remember my mom
she's a devout christian right and i
haven't told her i'm a muslim yet
but i told her i don't believe jesus is
god and she was like oh that really
and i even remember her when i was
little she would be
if i read the quran i have a feeling
that it's more true than the bible
she told me that um
so i know for a long time i've wanted to
read the quran
and i think that with y'all's
you know it's something that repeatedly
showed itself to me
you know islam just kept showing itself
and i need
it was something that i knew i needed to
check out so i started reading
the quran and started really researching
what islam was all about
and as soon as i did that i mean it
didn't take long to convert
my faith grew that night it wasn't solid
and it grew because i figured out how to
deal with
gin and chaton and i was sitting in my
room
and i just felt this evil presence all
around me
and it was it felt like there were three
or four gin
and they kept saying you know god is
narcissistic you know
he should have just created you and let
you do what you want to do he's arrogant
you know he's full of himself
why is it your purpose to
worship him you know why should you
spend your whole life worshiping him
and then i realized
[Music]
i was like damn assalamualaikum
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dona it's your boy five with rami
and angel
and we're joined with a very special
guest today
for a subscriber reaper story salaam
alaikum jared
alaikum al-salam thank you all for
having me on
man thank you for being here i know how
did you two meet
well one of those nights when i was
working late on the street
and doing some prostitution uh i found
him on the uh
the corner two two blocks down from mine
and we just hit it off bro we knew it
was trying to get out the game
so uh you know alhamdulillah yeah
damn bro you still wearing that same
sports bra yeah
he's trying to humble himself trying to
remember his boots
yes he's trying to himself so
we used to start we started talking
before you were muslim
now you're muslim yes tell me how that
happened
a lot of research but and a lot of faith
too um because i've wanted truth for a
while and i think that
you know hell he's a revert he'll
understand
i was looking for the truth for a long
time and i was just into some crazy
stuff like i was that eccentric guy who
was like
always trying you know going to buddhist
temples and
meditating and taking cold showers and
doing you know crazy type of stretching
and
you know new age spirituality all this
stuff but
it's just because i was for the truth
and religion is really complicated
and i think that you know the religions
that are false are complicated on
purpose
because i i kept trying to find god and
i just
it felt impossible to be honest with you
like it just
it was so exhausting um because i just
didn't
what is that i said what were you born
into
i don't even know to be honest with you
i mean my whole family is catholic but i
went to a baptist church first
then i went to a catholic church and
then i went to i don't even know what
the third one was
but my parents they were like oh yeah no
matter what religion you are as long as
you believe
in jesus you know you can do whatever
you go to heaven you know
okay i know how'd that sit with you
i never considered myself christian to
be honest
like even when i was going um
i could have been whatever religion true
or false but
as a kid you don't really know but yeah
i mean
i at no point would anybody come up to
me and i would be like 100
i'm christian you know i believe in it
at no point in my life would i have ever
reminded me of this one time uh i think
they told angel to say
jesus is your lord and savior and then
anna was like nah god is my lord and
savior
without even knowing like it was just a
fitra
bro when they told me that
now go ahead bro
when they told me that or like when they
said uh
repeat after me jesus is your lord and
savior
i just looked into the woman's eyes deep
into her soul bro and i was like
god is my lord and savior bro she was so
heated bro like she did not want to put
me under the water but she had to
because there was a line there was like
other people behind me
i swear when she put me in the water she
held me down there for a while
all right
i look brutal honestly i found that
funny man
i think she held you for extra long bro
no i think jerry is frozen bro probably
no no i'm here oh he was just
yeah he was just impressed he was no he
does that he does that just
he doesn't say nothing he's like listen
listen
so tell me how your
experience with islam and your journey
changed in the last few months
you said you were doing a lot of new
weight stuff and
uh what happened
uh well a lot of that stuff a lot of the
way stuff has
truth to it you know but it's not the
whole message
um it says i know i've heard angels say
this
and i know it will all of you if you
just take little bits and pieces and
choose whatever you want to choose it
doesn't really work
so you know like meditation is good you
know eating healthy or whatever whatever
you get into it's all good
um but with islam i remember my mom
she's a devout christian right and i
haven't told her i'm a muslim yet
but i told her i don't believe jesus is
god and she was like oh that really
and i even remember her when i was
little she would be
if i read the quran i have a feeling
that it's more true than the bible
she told me that um
so i know for a long time i've wanted to
read the quran
and i think that with y'alls
you know it's something that repeatedly
showed itself to me
you know islam just kept showing itself
and i need
it was something that i knew i needed to
check out so i started reading
the quran and started really researching
what islam was all about
and as soon as i did that i mean it
didn't take long to convert
what were some barriers along the way
my ego to be honest with you
i mean
it hasn't been as bad as i thought it
would be but a lot you just have this
feeling
up west that you could be like
an outlaw or people are going to hate
you and some people do to be honest
people don't understand
you know when you tell some people that
your mum are like friends family
they just get angry and they start
yelling at you you know
like jesus is god jesus is the son
like that but it hasn't been bad to be
honest um
but still just to completely one eight
change you know change your career
give up some of the things that you were
doing before in the name of allah it's
it's a lot it's a lot it's a huge change
and i mean
um angel i know you like a year ago
i'm a completely different person
completely different
yeah man i mean we started on the block
so we we came a long way you know
my brother tell them tell them what you
were getting into
before and like how you really wanted to
get into it and then
um like when i came on to islam and then
you started asking questions
about the um the thing that you were
gonna you know get into
and uh you slowly came to your own
realizations or allah basically
opened your your eyes and gave you the
answers that you were looking
as far as career or religion
nah bro come on now the thing that we've
been talking about
for over a year
i don't want to give away your story
it's your story bro no
well i need to know a story the poker
okay okay yeah so
ever since i was a little kid i've loved
her i remember
being five six years old i'm going to
sleep watching poker
and i have just like thinking numbers i
can calculate read people stuff like
that so when i was 18
i got a fake id i went to the casino and
i was just like boom this is my purpose
for life
and i just felt so happy to be at a
poker table
so for a long time 22 now for four years
i've just been consumed
with poker money you know and trying to
make it
man i was all over me all of a sudden
y'all see this
but for a long time that's all
everyone i wake up thinking about poker
you know thinking about poker and that
was my whole dream for life and during
14 it was a really good opportunity
because casinos got shut down so i
started running a game
and uh
prior to this every time i played poker
i didn't have any
like moral judgment about i didn't feel
bad at all and my game started growing
growing growing and then
right when it's like on the verge you'll
know when you start to become
successful at anything you can
kind of tell right like all the momentum
was building up
and i was just like damn i need to stop
you know something told me i need to
stop and i'll start getting depressed
every time i would play poker or anytime
i would run my game or whatever it was
and then i remember god came to me
really clear
and he was like jared you need to stop
this
and i was like okay i'm gonna stop i
went to sleep woke up in the morning i
was like
nah i'm not gonna stop i kept doing it
so
living hell
this was actually around
uh that you woke up and you were like
nah i'm gonna keep going
but yeah you're like you're kind of out
of here right now like we we see you
completely frozen
yeah do you have like
oh yeah yeah i've got the worst floors
so this conversation was right around
christmas because i remember i was at my
mom's house on her couch
right now staying over there for
christmas
i woke up today i was like nah never
mind gonna keep playing poker gonna keep
running my game yo you can turn off your
video real quick
just keep your audio on because the
audio is gonna be much better than
okay
every time i play poker anytime i would
run my game i would get
so depressed and i just have this
feeling that was wrong and i started
like consistently lose money or people
that have a bad day because of
whatever i'm like thinking about the um
outcome of that i'm like man are they
going home to their kids or
you know not being able to feed their
kids or even if it's not that i'm like
man these people have families
and they're sitting here you know 30
hours a week
and playing poker they should be with
their families they should be on the
purpose they should be so i started to
really see the negative benefit
or outcome of that and i hadn't
committed
but i know that you know talking to a
bunch of different people from
christianity or from
buddhism or from islam that there's no
religion that condones gambling
you know so i decided to just cut it off
cold turkey you know just drop it and
not float anymore
discontinue it really really soon after
that you know i made a lot of other
leaps of faith too but that was the
hardest
and really soon after islam revealed
itself a hundred percent to me
bro i remember last time we spoke not
last time a couple times we spoke
because you're on the patreon
right for the to the coaching calls here
i remember the first
time we spoke your ego was not letting
you
accept islam it was just such a
different paradigm shift and
it reminds me of when i was figuring out
the truth
and i hear that with a lot of people too
um
that actually in and of itself reminds
me of this thing you told us about
the i don't know if you want to share
bro honestly if you don't you don't have
to
the experience that you had with the
woman
not with the woman i'm talking about the
when it was like a gin it was trying to
my faith was actually my faith grew that
night it wasn't solid and it grew
because i figured out how to deal with
gin and chaton and i was sitting in my
room
and i just felt this evil presence all
around me
and it was it felt like there were three
or four gin and they kept saying you
know
god is narcissistic you know he should
have just created you and let you do
what you want to do
he's arrogant you know he's full of
himself why is it your purpose
to worship him
you know why should you spend your whole
life worshiping him and then i realized
that it wasn't my own thoughts you know
because sometimes you beat yourself up
for think and stuff like that and i
realized it was
whatever was around me so i just started
talking to him
and i saw how
yeah you got powerful so why are you
here talking bad about him
you know you know you could say all
those things if you want but god
is all-powerful and if he would will
he'd be able to make your life a living
hell
he would be able to give you anything or
take it away from you
so how are we going to sit here and talk
about him like how are we going to sit
here and talk bad about
god or question him or because we
everybody knows
john knows better than anybody god's
power so why is he disobeying
you know and it's through god's will
that shatan even has the ability
to talk to us in the first place so
my faith was tested because after that i
mean i'm able to handle
negative thoughts and lapses in faith a
lot better
that's crazy man isn't it crazy
that when you meditate it's like
supposedly
you're supposed to become aware of the
negative thoughts and you do
you become aware of the negative
thoughts but it's it doesn't make it any
easier
to overcome them like you still gotta
deal with them
but it's like when when you have this
this direction
this instruction manual is like oh well
yeah the negative thoughts come but you
understand
why the negative thoughts are coming you
understand where they come from
and you understand how to deal with the
negative thoughts
where it's like supernatural that that's
a game changer
um bro how has life changed for you
it it's easier to get through like uh
so i'm a meat cutter at a restaurant and
my my goal is to be really good at that
and progress up the ranks and since i
have a daughter i only work four days a
week
and i get about 55 to 60 hours in those
four days so you all already know
like i'm blessed it's a great job i love
it and i'm yeah
inshallah gonna be sticking with it and
doing good things for a while but
it's tough to get through those four
days especially when you're fasting and
i remember this one day
i was so dehydrated that my vision was
spotty i had slept like two hours three
nights in a row
and i was still back there just happy
you know like this
pain i had a headache from being
dehydrated and i was like you know what
i'm sitting here complaining but god
sent me down he gave me the book
that if i follow it and i do everything
in that book i'm gonna be good and i'm
gonna spend my life in eternal paradise
and he put me in this situation right
now to test me
so i'm just gonna keep praising him and
that's it and after that like i was
still in pain i was still tired
but i mean i mean you could be in so
much pain
and all you have to do is just keep
praising god and not let your faith drop
that's it like that that is it it is so
it's so simple it is
you're right bro marshall
it's all the tests it's all the tests to
see if we go
if we're going to come back come back to
allah
and bro it's either you you go to your
ego you go to others
which one you're going to go to
yeah and there's only one that's
infinite there's only one
x all powerful bro
all praise the most high allah bro
real quick bro because we got a five ish
minutes before we gotta wrap this up
any words of advice or wisdom to anyone
that was
exactly where you were when you were
kind of battling the ego
and this new paradigm
yeah the biggest thing is
even if you haven't accepted islam you
know right from wrong like
you know your feature brought you here
so if you're like me you know i had a
problem with celibacy
i had a problem because my ego took a
lot of yeah
that was a big problem with my ego as
well you know and i had a problem giving
up my job
gambling just do it like what's it going
to hurt
what is it going to hurt you know
because
we're talking spending the rest of your
life in heaven or
how much would you pay for that you know
if you're talking about giving up a job
making money or doing something that
you're passionate for
like what do you have to lose to be
honest with you
is there so much more at stake than just
right here right now
and to be honest with you once you
convert anyway
it's going to be better than it was
before you know you just don't think it
is because
the jin shatan he's got a hold of you so
just whatever you know you need to give
up be real with yourself give it up
that's it and stick with it no matter
what keep going you don't have to be
100 muslim the first day but it happens
so quick once you
once you show god you're willing to take
that step
i mean boy
what a wonderful note romney uh oh no
y'all got anything to say
whatever let me go honestly just
marshall love me i love bless you you've
come a long way
like you know like i was saying before
and uh it's tremendous so may allah
reward you immensely
and uh accept it from your habibi i mean
bro i've literally seen his
evolution from the first coaching call
through the coaching calls to now
every time i see you you're just more
and more happier and if not
you just you just look more fulfilled
bro you look more at peace you look more
like
you're not looking anymore the first day
was kind of like you're looking and
you're kind of puzzled
and you have a lot of overwhelming thing
and i know you did a ton of research bro
you did a ton of research
you experienced it you stopped leading
and just started being led by
and now you're just at peace bro
[Music]
and i see y'all's transformations too
like
i mean all you all have come a long way
it's inspiring you know everybody wants
to follow success
yeah i can look at each and every one of
you and
[Music]
listen it's been over a year that me and
you met on the black bro
listen we've come a hell of a long way
bro because i remember we were first
talking
it was it was all about women look hey
maybe
maybe we still talk about women you know
let's be honest
but it's a different light now look at
that bro alhamdulillah both of us
are now on the straight path
also on dean bro
that's what's up yeah there's not much
else to say rami
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hmm
hmm